all right let's do a little bit of
follow-up about what is the most
disgusting moment during any state of
the union address that i can remember
and at this point this is an important
story because
it wasn't just that lauren bobert
heckled joe biden during the state of
the union
and it wasn't just that lauren beaubert
radical republican congresswoman heckled
joe biden when biden was talking about
his son who died and served in the
military
during the state of the union but it's
about the fact that so many republicans
are refusing to condemn it and it's
about the fact that many in right-wing
media are celebrating what lauren bobert
did and it's absolutely and completely
disgusting so let's start with our first
example this is a republican congressman
james comer
who was given the opportunity to condemn
uh what lauren bobert did remember
marjorie taylor greene also yelling out
and turning her back to joe biden and he
doesn't do it he doesn't do it and it
wouldn't be that difficult to do it you
could do it in a way where you st you
still say
i mean listen at this point
you could say i completely condemn what
they did
but i also am worried about xyz thing
that biden did right like it's pretty
straightforward to put together a
statement like that
that's not what he does look at look at
this disgusting response congressman
before we let you go i do want to ask
you about what we all saw and heard
frankly last night from the chamber two
of your colleagues lauren bobert
margelin taylor green were shouting at
the president throughout his speech one
moment that i think a lot of people
heard she shouted out 13 of them when
the president was talking about soldiers
in a flag draped coffins do you think
that type of behavior is appropriate
well certainly
whether you agree or disagree with the
president i believe during the state of
the union uh we should all show respect
to the president
but honestly but honestly
but honestly this is the same and we'll
get the this is like those tweets
putin shouldn't invade ukraine
but and then something horrible follows
it share their frustration when you look
at the crises that we're facing in this
country
but should they be should they be
vocalizing that in the middle of his
state of the union address does that not
undercut your party and its messaging on
those critical issues
well it's certainly not my style
i've heard that type of behavior from
democrats to when we had republican
presidents no actually no that's not
true that's not true
there have the two main heckling
incidents are joe wilson heckling barack
obama and billboard and green heckling
joe biden those are the incidents
i just think that the best yellow
business model democrats yelled at a
republican president in the chamber when
did that happen
yeah well when donald trump was was
president so the the thing that
you know
that's not true i think congress should
do is just listen and then we have an
opportunity like i'm doing now to speak
to the america and speak to the press
about our disagreements and move on
all right congressman james so what do
you guys think i mean it's it's not like
bobert and greene are so prominent in
the party leadership that these are
people that you can't be
um
adversarial with or whatever the case
may be like is this is this guy a coward
is he merely a bad person like what do
you guys think is the explanation
because it's not exactly a profile in
courage
and um it's even
less likely to be condemned
when right-wing media is sort of
cheerleading the entire thing and that's
what i want to talk about next